welcome back to css3 in 30 days guess
what's happening today we are going to
be making an 8-bit super mario with just
css3 I'm not joking check it out over
here we got day 8 8-bit super Mario or
8-bit Mario what's gonna happen here is
check it out that that's what we're
gonna make in CSS and then I just had
this little kind of CSS animation when
you click the wahoo button see something
like that the sounds you have to provide
yourself but that's what we're gonna be
doing and so it's pretty interesting how
it's done the HTML is beautifully simple
and if only that were all you had to do
then that would be pretty cool but the
CSS is a little bit interesting and I'll
show you why now keep in mind this isn't
necessarily a practical use of css3 I
don't know how many times I've ever been
paid to make Super Mario in CSS except
for now whoa let's head over to our
course files here and download the 8 bit
number 8 8 bit Super Mario project files
you'll go ahead and do that and come
back right here to this part of the
video and what's gonna happen here is we
have our index sandbox of final CSS as
usual here in the index check out the
markup I'm gonna go down to the final
result here all we have is a button a
div with the class of mario block and
final Mario I always prepend final
double underscore for the final
resigning CSS so let's go up to the
sandbox this is all the markup you're
going to be using so we have the button
and this is Mario here Mario block and
Mario 2 divs that is pretty cool so how
does this work let's go over to the
browser again and I'm just going to
inspect this and show you what's going
on here
SuperMario is in a div called mario
block so here he is he's in a block it's
320 by 320 pixels I have it set up as 16
m by 16 m and it will get into the
measurements in a moment here in there
we have final Mario and there's simply
just one line going across it's one by
one block which is 20 by 20 pixels or as
we can see here 1m now you can see that
there are 16 blocks going across that's
because we've set up in final Mario
block 16 M so this is 16 by 16 which
equates to 320 and 320 pixels in this
case and so that means that container
were working with is 16 by 16 and each
block of the Mario pixel I guess we
could say because he's an 8-bit so he's
like a 16 pixel sort of thing
the width is 1m so we have 1m and 16 of
those fit across so final Mario is
officially just 1 M by 1 M and what
we're doing here is using a bunch of box
shadows you can see his colors here look
at that that is hairy
but that is how we do it we just have a
box shadow that has multiple values
separated by comma just putting the
place in the colors on a grid so for
example zero and zero is the top left
and then one and zero is one M over and
a you know it's at the top so it goes in
that sort of grid like fashion so that
is how we make Mario using just box
shadows so go over to your let me show
you here in the final CSS you can see
how it works we have box shadow and then
a bunch of values now I'm not gonna make
you watch me code all these values out
we'll all get started to show you the
pattern and then I'm going to leave it
up to you to finish it
now you're going to need to reference
the fit the final version pretty pretty
closely but keep in mind you're working
on a grid a 16 by 16 grid you simply
you're just kind of painting by numbers
or CSS hanging by numbers let's jump
into our sandbox let's Google get
started with the basics so we're gonna
style the mario block that is the
container wrapping it all we're gonna
say display:inline-block
position:relative margin eighty pixels
auto width 16 m height 16 m the reason
why we're using m's here is because the
container within the mario block which
is just called mario when we use m's
it's rep it's referencing the vat the
size of its parent whereas when you're
using rim it's relative to the root so
with M it's relative to its parent so
when I say 16 by 16 m
that is the height and width of the
mario block container you can see here
in the browser we've got a container
here that is in theory 16 by 16 m/s now
what we'll do is we will do basic styles
here for just Mario display block width
1 M height 1 M so now officially we have
1 let's call them pixels just for this
moment they're not actual pixels this
one m block is gonna be like one big-ass
pixel and there's 16 of them going
across and 16 of them going down so now
you just have to draw Mario using box
shadows within that so let's just say
the background color will be the that
blue background we have here in the
container East 7 double ef-1 okay this
is where the magic happens
let's say box shadow and I'm going to go
0 M 0 M and E 7 de F 1 so that is the
first line that's the top left 0 1 0 is
gonna be that blue so what's gonna
happen here is we want this here is here
is Mario this is officially his size
right here let me just inspect him there
we go
so very is right there so this first
block is going to be that blue second
block blue third fourth fifth all the
way to 16th is all blue then we go down
one M blue blue blue blue
guess what next one red red red red blue
blue Mario skin color Mario skin color
Mario skin color - gotta kind of gotta
get that so now let's go here and I'm
just gonna start adding some numbers I'm
gonna just blast through the first row
of blue fast-forward it and and then
we'll start getting into just the first
little bit of Mario and then we'll take
it from there
so first line that
you
one m0m and i'm gonna copy that blue
color there so the next one over this is
XV x axis and y axis so this means it's
going across horizontally this means
it's going down so we're just going one
over none down next one copy this whole
line and I'm just going to say 2 & 0
then 3 & 0 then 4 & 0 then 5 and 0 we're
gonna do this all the way until you
guessed it 15 because you don't need to
do the 16th and I just last year that
now
all right so I've got the first row here
of blue you're not gonna see it at all
because it's just the background color
so now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna go down one row here one pixel on
the y-axis and we're gonna go over
however many blocks that is until we get
to the top of his head his hat so let's
start that off comma and then we're
gonna go we're going down now to the
next level so I'm gonna give another
space that maybe that will work just for
visual purposes and now let's say we're
going to go 0 m and 1 M blue again
copy that we're going to do that up
until the fourth M one two three four
that's all blue now you're not gonna see
anything yet but now if I go with the
next row or the next M over we're
actually gonna start with his hat so
that's just gonna be flat red so we're
still now we're at 5m and 1m so we're
one down and we're five over red let's
just save that I want to semicolon and
save that and see if we have anything
bam we have the first official pixel of
Mario's hat now watch what happens when
I add more and I'm gonna go over six and
then just go seven all the way up until
nine so seven save that semicolon at the
end if you want to view it look at that
we've got the first sliver of his hat
and that part right there so the next
couple are gonna be blue and then three
of his skin tones so let's go ahead and
do those together and then I'm gonna get
you to keep going by yourself here but
I'll give you the colors before you go
so the next one is going to be ten it's
going to be ten and one and that blue
color so E 7e ef-1 we're gonna do two of
these so one two that's gonna be 11 and
now we're going to do the skin tone so
let's go sweet 12 13 14 15
so that would be 12 13 14 and 15
the skin tone that we have set here for
Mario is FF c 9 6 6 copy that paste it
out a couple to a few times there
semicolon at the end to test save let's
head over here look at this we've got
the first layer so we've got first the
first row and the second row which you
can start to see it start to take shape
that's what it will turn into this is
what it is right here
so let's quickly do the next one and
then you're kind of on your own here I
know I keep saying that but I'm just
gonna I'm just going to do that so we
have just a bunch of red so we have from
2 down so we got we got we're at 0 now
and now we're at 2 so 2 down 0 so you're
at the left two M's down and red so now
we're going to do this all the way up
until 12 m and all red so 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 change those numbers out
real quick
and now save that semicolon at the end
to test to save it head over now we
should be mmm okay we don't you can see
here mario has a few blue pixels there
and I put them all over there so I just
need to change the first few from red
and to that blue color the blue brand
color so it's gonna be this one's going
to be that color then number two is
gonna be that color and number three is
going to be that color save it head back
over now we're talking now it is more
like it needs to be the last couple here
it even looks like perhaps the one two
three four this one has one two
three I think that's three yes that's
three so this tone up here is actually
gonna be number 15 and one it's gonna be
that so it should look more like this
there we go and now these two have to be
the skin tone so you kind of guessed it
here copy this do you do this is going
to change to that East 7/8 EF 1 and
these values are gonna be 13 and 14
actually no that's not the skin tone the
skin tone is FFC 966 and then 15 is e 7
e EF 1 semicolon save that now we've
officially got our second row you can
see that it's starting to take shape so
now what you're gonna do is go through
and map these out yourself because
obviously this would be the longest
video ever if I'm gonna write you know
Oh 300 lines of black shadows so I'm
gonna leave that up to you do it just
actually do it and try it yourself and
if you get bored you can you know move
on but try it it's kind of an
interesting challenge to you know go
through this and map Mario out now what
I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna quickly
fast forward this video have it be
finished and then I'm gonna show you how
to do the wahoo button just because so
I'm gonna go ahead and do that before
I'm actually gonna give you the final
colors so you can obviously go to the
final CSS but Brown is just Brown there
is just blue and yellow okay so you are
okay and I believe that there is like a
black in there for his eyes
so those are your final colors you don't
even need me to tell you what this this
is you already got these colors this is
brown this is yellow this is blue and
then that's black so you'll be fine
now we're going to do is I'm going to
fast forward this and then show you how
to do the animation so here we go there
is Mario there is all the styles there
the final box shadows there and so now
what we're gonna do is I'm just going to
show you real quick how to do the the
animation this one right here whoa cool
so we've done this before I think the
animations it's just keyframes and
animations it's pretty straightforward
so let's go ahead and do that I'm gonna
style it up here so it's easier to see
and we're gonna start off with wha who
is the ID for the button outline:none
because the I don't want that that ugly
outline there so outline:none and we're
gonna go and say wahoo active so when
you are actively clicking it sibling
selector it's gonna be mario block we're
selecting that and what we're gonna do
is say animation we're gonna give an
animation we're gonna call it
wahoo Mario it's gonna be a 0.8 seconds
ease in out and loop it once and then
we're just gonna build a keyframe so
keyframes and we're gonna call it
wahoo Mario and then at 0%
we're gonna say left zero bottom zero
transform rotate and it's going to be
zero at the beginning I'm gonna copy
this out paste paste paste change the
percentages of the timeline to 30% 80%
and 100% so at these different intervals
this is where we're going to at these
kind of stops we're going to do they
make the animation do something so it's
going to go to 200 pixels left and 200
pixels from the bottom up it's going to
rotate negative 25 degrees and 80% we're
going to do 400 pixels bottom is going
to be 0 and then 0 left's is gonna be
100% left to 0 bottom is 0 and transform
we could just take that right out now if
I save that and head back over here
click the button wahoo just like that
there is your Mario awesome good job
good job this was a doozy of a lesson
like I said not really a practical
application of css3 but I mean if
anything you got to see that you could
do some pretty cool things and then some
animations you know mapping things out
on grids it's pretty cool um I don't
know how often you're gonna be doing
this sort of sort of thing it's more
sort of just a challenge and just to
show you this is kind of a cool thing so
I hope you enjoyed that lesson we've got
some more great stuff coming up for day
9 thanks for hanging out with me for so
long
[Music]